ragazzi finalmente stiamo facendo le
cose in grande e il canale è cambiato
stiamo facendo un sacco di video
qualitativi e ho bisogno assolutamente
di una persona che mi affianchi nell'afa
vj tv e oggi quindi faremo dei colloqui
per assumere il mio nuovo collaboratore
ufficiale del corpo perfetto è bello mio
ufficio un bellissimo perché ciò 62
penne non lo so facilitano il primo joy
fanno entrare salto di san salvi salve
ciao ciao
si beh corri con un sì comunque avremo
bisogno di una persona da inserire
all'interno dello staff
tutto bene sì sì
ma è qui per il colloquio proprio qua
buongiorno ciao allora come lavorare per
questo fantomatico fa vj e beh sono sono
io ieri
tu non sai che sono ma specialmente a
fare un colloquio e non sai chi sono
quello faccio
io faccio video su youtube
youtube internet
internet
no
george chiamami prossimo sostanzialmente
la previgente inter paesi molto
importante quindi abbiamo bisogno di
persone determinate sicure
anzi
interessante due lauree conosciuto
lingue ha avuto un'esperienza lavorativa
ventennale alla guida di tre diversi
colossi finanziari ha salvato la vita al
presidente mattarelli due volte
ha salvato la vita dei passeggeri di un
boeing 747
facendo atterrare nel tevere
scoperto la cura per una malattia che
ancora una strana scoperta
ancora in qualunque se come dicono in
america proprio sky's the limit
come no dico sky's the limit
avete un problema con l'antenna sul
tetto
com ett
in pratica sarebbe un'esperienza in
grado di arricchirsi lavorativamente a
360 gradi
ecco a proposito di arricchirmi quanto
ma
sarebbe comunque un normale stipendio
adeguato al ruolo
ma ma più o meno scusami quant'è che ti
aspettavi un coniglio rosso forse sono i
modellini quelli vero pronto sì cosa
no
una vacanza in un hotel a cinque stelle
lusso ma certo che ci sono anzi adesso
pure un nuovo lavoro che me lo può
permettere sì sì assolutamente dai ci
sentiamo dai
ci sono almeno tre mesi di vacanza vero
centro
no perché stavo per il caldo non sarebbe
male
forse non ci siamo capiti ma senti
l'atto aziendale
l'africa stavo vedendo maiori comunque
veloce perché capace lamborghini guarda
che cambia
poggiati
george
l'ambulanza
veloce
hai fatto atterrare anche un boeing sul
tevere
no ai l'ansia no
vuoi un sacco di soldi no non lo fai se
sei qua sto cercando il proprietario di
una mustang basta sì proprio la massa
che a quella qua sotto volendo più a
fila si sommano e tre ore che ti cerco
ma la vuoi levare
va bene ragazzi io vi più prospettati e
secondo me la soluzione per voi è una
sola ed è o peggio metis e cos'è openjob
e metis e un'agenzia per il lavoro in
italia da oltre vent'anni che fa
incontrare le persone che cercano con le
aziende che offrono
ci sono un sacco di filiali dove trovi
dei recruiter che sono un punto di
riferimento per te che ne ha bisogno ad
esempio è che aiutano a compilare il
curriculum ti aiutano a capire come
presentati i colloqui di lavoro che
sarebbe il caso è da trovare la propria
tanto a te punto particolarmente ogm
ricordatevi che un po preparata ti offre
corsi di formazione gratuiti per
l'appeal nuove competenze per i servizi
all'interno del mondo le loro
tra l'altro tutti i servizi sono
completamente in viola tweet i no dico
sempre che quei soldi vista due o tre
problemi in oltre allo stipendio che
percepire sti sarebbe lo stesso che
percepirebbe se fossi assunta
direttamente dall'azienda
e poi non è che serve proprio che ti
metti tutte ste cose nel curriculum da
mattarella due volte una
e infine c'è la giorni gioco per
rivoluzionare completamente il mondo del
lavoro in italia perche con questa tesi
e conoscere non mi fa cercando lavoro
potete sfogliare i vari annunci trovare
il lavoro più adatto a lui e segnale più
segnalate persone più prendere due punti
e se queste persone vengono assunte
accumulate ancora più punti che potete
utilizzare per ottenere delle
riserve grazie grazie
ora basta spostiamo
sconvolto
ma
la rai ha respiro profondo
state caricate
è un'agenzia per il lavoro con sedi in
tutta italia da oltre vent'anni e cosa
fanno
passeggiano gaza
dopo aver ammesso alla viglia morire
temi blu permetti libia
eppure il complice
no non so chi sia